bonsoir mangeront nous de la fosse
viande en 2050
on voit là une question inattendue mais
quel est le problème
en 2050 nous aurons 9 milliards de
bouches à nourrir
ce qui est très difficile voire
impossible si on ne change pas nos modes
de consommation
les scientifiques s'accordent
aujourd'hui pour dire que notre soutien
notre société doit faire face à de
nombreux problèmes
ainsi il nous faut augmenter le niveau
de nos ressources alimentaires pour
satisfaire les besoins physiologiques
notamment en protéines d'une population
humaine toujours croissante tout en
réduisant le gaspillage en augmentant
l'efficience de l'agriculture tout en
continuant à produire de la viande et du
lait et des produits végétaux de qualité
tout en réduisant le mal être supposé
des animaux d'élevage dans certains
types d'élevages intensifs et enfin tout
en réduisant la dégradation de
l'environnement par les activités
humaines notamment l'élevage
en effet nous savons aujourd'hui qui
grâce à leur capacité à digérer la
cellulose des végétaux les ruminants et
les vaches produisent un puissant gaz à
effet de serre le méthane est ce méthane
il est re larguée dans l'atmosphère
non pas quand les vaches pète comme
c'est dit souvent mais en réalité quand
les vaches roth et ceux ci c'est la
contrepartie de l'aptitude des
herbivores à valoriser la cellulose des
végétaux et à transformer cette
cellulose en viande et en les équipes
usa il est écrit partout qu'il faudrait
quinze mille litres d'eau pour produire
un kilo de viande de boeuf et l'élevage
occupe 30 % des terres émergées et 70%
des terres agricoles
il ya donc là de nombreux problèmes et
les scientifiques se sont
parent est emparé à bras le corps de
tous ces problèmes et certains
scientifiques proposent des solutions
inattendue surprenante
ainsi par exemple le professeur ikeda
qui est un scientifique japonais a mis
au point une technique pour purifier des
protéines à partir de n'importe quelle
source de protéines pour les rendre
comestibles et aujourd'hui et purifie
les protéines à partir des boues
d'épuration de la ville de tokyo
il est capable de fabriquer un burger à
partir d'excréments humains en y
rajoutant un petit peu de soja et de
sauce tech
bon appétit
d'autres scientifiques ont eu une idée
géniale
les scientifiques de l'université de
maastricht aux pays bas
des scientifiques aux états unis en
israël sont capables de faire multiplier
un très très grand nombre de cellules
musculaires un très très grand nombre de
fois pour produire une très très grande
quantité de muscles et donc de la viande
pour nourrir l'humanité
il faut dire aussi quand même malgré
tout que le muscle ainsi produit
ressemble davantage à un burger d'un
fast-food plutôt qu'à un véritable
muscles dans toute sa complexité avec
les nerfs et les vaisseaux sanguins et
ses équipes usées savez vous combien a
coûté le premier burger artificielle en
deux cent cinquante mille euros la
presse plébiscitent cette découverte
révolutionnaire il y à un engouement
médiatique pour la viande artificielle
et comment explique-t-on cet engouement
médiatique
parce que les citoyens sont aujourd'hui
des citadins ils sont loin ils ont
oublié en fait ils sont moins des
campagnes ils ont oublié que la viande
est produite à partir d'animaux vivants
comme jadis dans nos campagnes et qui
plus est le respect de la vie animale
la peur du futur sont également des
raisons de cet engouement est donc selon
les promoteurs de la viande artificielle
on peut produire une quantité infinie de
muscles et donc de viande pour produire
pour nourrir l'humanité
sans gaspiller nos ressources la viande
serait d'excellente qualité
parce qu'elle aurait exactement la
composition voulue par les chercheurs
on n'aurait plus à des animaux et
l'élevage ne regarderai plus
l'environnement
tout cela est il vrai oui en effet notre
société doit augmenter le niveau des
ressources alimentaires pour satisfaire
la population humaine toujours
croissante
mais de là à ne plus manger de viande
car il faudrait 7 kilos de protéines
végétales pour produire un kilo de boeuf
ça se discute
la viande serait mauvaise pour
l'environnement et les avions
d'artificiel pour l'urée mois cela se
discute aussi est tout à fait exact de
dire que l'élevage occupe 30 % des
terres émergées et 70% des terres
agricoles
mais une grande partie de ses terres
correspond aux savanes africaines au
steak mongolienne aux prairies de
montagne etc etc et on ne peut pas faire
de culture dans ces territoires pour
produire directement des végétaux que
l'on peut manger et dire aussi que la
viande serait mauvaise pour la santé et
la viande artificielle de meilleure
qualité
cela se discute aussi commençons donc
par la question de l'efficacité
oui il faut en moyenne 6,7 kilos de
protéines végétales pour fabriquer un
kilo de protéines animales avec une
grande variabilité de 3,50
ces chiffres qui sont mis en en exergue
en comparaison pour discréditer
l'alimentation carnée au profit de
l'alimentation végétarienne mais ces
chiffres cachent une autre vérité
en réalité je vous le dis quatre vingt
pour cent des aliments que l'on donne
aux arts vivants ne sont pas directement
comestible par l'homme pourquoi parce
que les herbivores consomme de l'herbe
des fourrages du foie et d'une façon
générale les animaux d'élevage
consomment les coûts produits et les
résidus des grandes cultures favorisant
ainsi
la durabilité de l'agriculture grâce à
des recyclages vertueux ainsi si l'on
tient compte uniquement des protéines
végétales comestibles et consommables
par l'homme dans les systèmes herbagers
il faudrait de l'ordre au minimum 0 2
kilos de protéines végétales comestibles
par l'homme pour produire un kilo de
protéines animales et donc dans ce cas
de figure les herbivores deviennent des
producteurs net de protéines puisqu'ils
produisent davantage de protéines qu'ils
consomment de protéines végétales
comestibles
une autre question concerne l'empreinte
en eau il existe une méthode universelle
pour calculer la consommation d'eau qui
est nécessaire pour produire un produit
ou un service
on peut calculer la consommation d'eau
pour une entreprise pour une ferme pour
un pays pour un bassin et dans cette
méthodologie on distingue trois types
d'eau
tout d'abord l'eau bleue qui est en fait
l'eau douce souterraines ou de surface
l'eau douce des rivières des lacs des
acquis faire il ya aussi l'eau grise qui
correspond à la quantité d'eau
nécessaire pour diluer les eaux usées
pour les rangs de nouveau utilisables il
ya aussi l'eau verte qui correspond à
l'eau de pluie et cette eau de pluie est
nécessaire pour faire pousser l'herbe
qui est mangée par les herbivores pour
produire de la viande et du lait
effectivement avec ce calcul il faut
quinze mille litres d'eau propos pour
produire un kilo de viande de boeuf
mais aujourd'hui les scientifiques ont
bien conscience que de toute façon
l'eau de pluie tomberez qu'il y ait ou
non des animaux pour manger l'herbe et
cette eau de pluie représente 93 5 % de
l'empreinte endo
et donc si on retire cette eau depuis il
ne faut plus que 50 à 700 litres d'eau
pour produire un kilo de boeuf et donc
il faut davantage d'eau pour produire du
blé que pour produire de la viande
concernant l'énergie les premières
publications ont affirmé qu' il faudrait
moins d'énergie pour produire de la
viande artificielle que pour produire de
la viande bovine ou de poulet ou de porc
mais en 2015
des publications plus récentes ont
montré que c'était exactement l'inversé
il faut davantage d'énergie pour
produire de la viande artificielle car
il faut chauffer les incubateurs géant
dans lesquelles il agrée cellules en
culture il faut les chauffer à 37 degrés
parce que les cellules ont besoin d'être
à 37 degrés il ya aussi un certain
nombre de vérités qui sont occultés
concernant la viande artificielle comme
je voulais dit cette viande est produite
à partir d'un très grand nombre de
cellules qui se multiplient un très très
grand nombre de fois et sur le lot il ya
toujours quelques cellules dont le
fonctionnement se dérègle
elle se transforme si vous voulez en
cellules cancéreuses vous consommateurs
est ce que vous voudriez manger des
cellules cancéreuses
aucun risque elles vont être détruites
par l'acidité gastrique
de quoi est fait le milieu de culture
dans l'ue meilleure culture
les cellules ont besoin de ces rentes de
vaud foetale qui apporte de nombreux
nutriments
donc il faut des veaux mais aujourd'hui
les chercheurs travaillent pour
remplacer ce sérum de vaud foetale par
un milieu de culture synthétique et qui
plus est dans ce milieu de culture il
faut rajouter des hormones synthétiques
à souligner d'exams états l'udc aux
corticoïdes etc et toutes ces hormones
devront être produites par l'industrie
chimique qui va nécessairement relarguer
des résidus de molécules de synthèse
dans ces eaux usées est ce que c'est bon
pour la santé
par ailleurs les cellules se multiplient
à 37 degrés mais les champignons et les
bactéries se multiplient aussi à 37
degrés il faut donc rajouter des
antibiotiques en très grand nombre et
des fongicides en très grand nombre donc
et vous compte tenu de ce que je vous ai
dit est ce que vous êtes prêts à acheter
et à consommer régulièrement de la
viande artificielle pour sauver
l'humanité consommateurs êtes vous prêt
à acheter consommer de la viande
artificielle
si oui lever la main en réalité nous
avons fait trois enquêtes
deux enquêtes par internet sur la
population française et sur la
population mondiale avec des
échantillons représentatifs et une
enquête après discussion face à face
avec les personnes interrogées dans les
trois en tête 50 à 70% des personnes
interrogées ne sont pas prêtes à acheter
et à consommer régulièrement de la
viande artificielle et un tiers ne sait
pas qu'en pensent les chercheurs
qu'en pense la communauté scientifique
internationale et notamment celle de
l'inra les chercheurs reconnaissent
qu'il y à de très nombreux verrous
techniques à lever avant de produire en
routine la viande artificielle notamment
à l'échelle industrielle et commerciale
il faut en effet fabriqué des
incubateurs géant chauffée à 37°
remplacer les milieux de culture etc etc
et par ailleurs les causes de la
malnutrition
aujourd'hui son rond sont rendus d'une
part au gaspillage alimentaire puisque
on gaspille 30% de nos ressources
alimentaires et d'autre part le
gaspillage alimentaire ou du moins la
malnutrition sont liées aussi à des
problèmes politiques et des problèmes de
corruption dans certains pays qui
empêchent d'acheminer l'aide alimentaire
vers les plus démunis
les chercheurs en sciences humaines et
sociales ont également observé que la
presse grand public donne une image
déformée de ce qu'est la viande
artificielle en mettant en avant ses
avantages potentiels et en minimisant
ses inconvénients
alors me direz-vous
quel est l'avenir de notre alimentation
comme je l ai déjà dit réduisons le
gaspillage alimentaire de la production
à la consommation y compris dans nos
frigos ce gaspillage alimentaire qui
représentent 30 % de notre production
totale est par ailleurs essayons aussi
de diversifier nos sources de protéines
alimentaires
il existe aujourd'hui sur le marché des
produits à base de protéines extraites
de champignons au début regard végétaux
et peut-être qu'un jour demain nous
mangerons des insectes
essayons aussi de faire évoluer nos
systèmes d'élevage
évitons les systèmes d'élevage trop
intensif qui ne sont pas favorables à
l'environnement ou au bien être animal
et dans lesquelles les animaux sont
nourris avec des céréales ou des
produits végétaux que l'homme pourrait
consommer directement au contraire
favorisons le développement de systèmes
d'élevage herbager où les animaux les
herbivores consomme l'herbe pâturée
consomme le foin que l'homme ne peut pas
consommer directement équipe usée le sol
des prairies naturelles stocks du
carbone atténuant ainsi le réchauffement
ou le changement climatique équipe usée
la présence des animaux dans les
campagnes contribuer à l'entretien du
paysage est aussi au maintien d'une
certaine activité économique et donc au
maintien d'un tissu rural
donc en conclusion la viande
artificielle n'est certainement pas la
solution miracle pour résoudre les
problèmes de l'humanité
au contraire il existe aujourd'hui
plusieurs solutions faciles à mettre en
oeuvre
complémentaires comme par exemple la
diversification de nos sources de
protéines alimentaires protéines
végétales protéines animales mangeons un
peu moins de viande dans les pays
développés mon jour davantage de viande
dans les pays en voie de développement
pour satisfaire les besoins
nutritionnels des populations essayons
d'adopter d'adapter nos systèmes
d'élevage aux conditions locales
favorisons les systèmes d'élevage à base
d'herbes et enfin comme je l'aï dit
plusieurs fois
réduisons le gaspillage alimentaire
merci pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]